So we unfortunately have to have today what
is a very real but admittedly depressing conversation,
and it's really about the future of the United
States, be it Biden or Trump, who wins in
November.
And I want to approach this from a slightly
different angle.
So let me let me sort of set it up for you.
The starting point is that in all likelihood,
more than 60 million Americans are going to
vote for four more years of Donald Trump in
November.
They're going to see they will have seen what
we saw for the last three and a half years
and they're going to say, I'm going to vote
for four more years of that.
And the important context here is that certainly,
depending on who wins the election, we are
changing the direction of the country in the
sense that if Donald Trump gets another four
years, that's one direction.
If Joe Biden replaces Donald Trump, that's
a completely different direction.
But I was having a conversation yesterday
with a former producer, Lewis, and we were
talking about sort of the outlook for the
country.
And inevitably, these discussions come up
about, you know, if Biden wins, then this
or if the Senate goes to Democrats than that
or if Trump, then this other path goes forward.
And, of course, the November election results
are going to have major consequences.
We've been looking at policy differences over
the last several months.
And when you look at tax policy, yesterday,
Donald Trump during his press briefing saying
that he would actually be cutting the capital
gains tax, whereas Joe Biden wants to tax
capital gains as ordinary income, which would
be.
I mean, these are really large differences
in policy.
Look at green New Deal elements that Joe Biden
is including in his climate plan versus what
Donald Trump has done.
I mean, just look at almost any policy and
you see that these are very different trajectories.
But there is a really big difference in terms
of outcome versus the makeup of the country.
And when it comes to voting, in all likelihood,
somewhere between 60 million and 66 million
people are going to vote for Donald Trump.
And maybe the range is a little bigger.
Maybe it's like at least 58 million and probably
no more than 68 million people are going to
vote for Donald Trump, but around 60 million
people are going to say this is the guy I
want.
So the point I'm making is that even if we
set the country on a different path in January
by electing Joe Biden in November, if Donald
Trump is indeed removed, somewhere around
half of the voters will have voted for Donald
Trump.
And this is not trivial.
This has real consequences day to day for
you and for me beyond what the president does.
So certainly, if you think about climate,
putting in Biden instead of Trump will make
a massive difference.
But spending on where you live, half of the
school committee you might be involved in
will be made up of Trump voters, up police
officers, doctors, accountants, the people
that we are going to be interacting with on
a daily basis.
Even if Joe Biden ekes out a win over Donald
Trump from the standpoint of the Electoral
College.
These folks aren't going away and their ideology
doesn't get changed or fixed because their
candidate loses the Electoral College.
And I don't know what the answer to that is.
And we've talked before in these segments
about Trump ism doesn't end when Donald Trump
leaves office, be it in January or January
of 2025.
That's not just a catchphrase.
It's not trivial.
It's not unimportant.
It's extraordinary, really.
And how do we start thinking about that?
Because it's such a bigger issue.
And, you know, there's this phrase that's
often mentioned at something like Trump didn't
create racists, but they're just more comfortable
out in public right now, much along the same
lines.
Donald Trump did not create anti intellectual
ism or pseudo intellectual ism.
We've done interviews and I've explained to
you that those ideologies have been around
since the eighteen hundreds in some form approximating
what we have today.
And they have been coalesced into a sort of
voting bloc at this point.
We saw it with George W. Bush and we see it
even more with with Donald Trump.
And so this is a bigger picture issue.
There's no doubt that much more than George
W. Bush.
Donald Trump has sort of coalesced and emboldened
this non-thinking crowd.
But once the election's over and hopefully
Trump leaves this January, it might not be
until January of 2025.
It remains to be seen what happens with that
anti intellectual non-thinking Trump ist ideology
that doesn't go away.
What happens in the Senate?
What happens in the House of Representatives?
This is not trivial and it's something that
we really have to think about.
And what no matter who wins the presidency,
there will.
Somewhere around 60 to 65 million people who
say what I saw the last three and a half years.
I voted for more of it.
Hopefully they won't get it, but we'll still
have to deal with those people.
And that gets me to the next topic I want
to discuss with you today, which actually
relates to the popular vote sort of in this
context.
So let's talk about
that next.